[Music]
hey here we are we might be drunk Todd
had one drink last night so we're going
to take it easy on him what you have a
red wine well get get a mic in front of
you Todd oh yeah good call I forgot
about
microphones uh I had a I had a lambow
man yeah by myself I know you had one
drink one little drink yeah oh easy BT a
lambu like it's a cold bubbly red wine
oh never heard of it it's really good
lamb can we look that up it's uh it's I
would call it easy drinking I'm not a
big drinker but if I
was wow lamb Brusco I'll check that out
cuz I like a bubbly wine yeah it's
bubbly it's red it's cold it's kind of
like everything okay I'm in Lamb Brusco
yeah Goes Down Easy are you you still in
East Village hey don't worry about sorry
no I'm in I'm kind of a little I'm I'm
the cusp of the East Village I know
where you're talking same building no I
moved in uh April 1st I moved ah we're
neighbors we uh yeah we're neighbors
okay I went to his C I mean even even if
you live close in New York there you
have your own there's 900 coffee shops
in that true yeah so I tried out his
coffee shop it's solid was good right
good coffee shop taste Todd yeah man
that's where I did Comedians in Cars oh
that coffee shop that's the second
coffee shop that I nice probably goes
down as the worst EP you know you're
right I mean why is it well just cuz I
can't believe I just took that like
without it I've seen them all 900 times
uh but you got I feel like it just
didn't click or he was trying to make a
joke out of how it didn't click that's
what I think he was doing yeah um I mean
it's just thing with that I mean I
didn't know we're going to talk about
this but I that's the beauty of a pod
yeah I mean people the problem is that
some people don't understand editing so
it's like he could have made me look
like I was the chatter box true shut the
up good point that I didn't talk
and he just went for I know it's fine I
don't I guess he must have liked the
episode episode or else he would have
scrapped it but yeah yeah but yeah I
think there's worse episodes by the way
I mean I definitely am I mean I I just
feel like with him like lenos is guest
well they they've been to a diner 600
times together you know what I mean or
something maybe more Larry David and
Jerry created a show be like a report
comfort and with me I'd known him for
decades just to say hi to him but I've
never had like a long conver I never
hung out with them ever that's the
tricky thing about podcast is like like
Mark and I have like this Rapport for so
many years but sometimes we'll go on
someone else's pod and they just go down
a road that we're like what the are
you totally and you've never this is the
first conversation you've ever had and
now it's public yeah into a microphone
it is like it almost is like a first
date that's broadcast it's weird and but
you're trying to be really funny and
plug dates other dates yeah um how how
cool are you with Jerry oh I'm fine I'm
yeah I mean I don't clearly he's a big
fan of yours yeah I mean I have the
phone message somewhere where he called
me and it was really because he somehow
got my number and I was just like like a
frozen yogurt shop and this call comes
through and I didn't take it and then I
checked H Todd this Jerry Seinfeld uh
you know Todd when I was on The Tonight
Show this guy called me and said uh you
want to do the show and I said yeah he
goes this is kind of like that call
something something along that but like
a minute and a half message wow yeah I
mean I do wish that I was
um I wish I would have Cut Loose a
little bit more but also I you know for
14 minutes out of four hours you could
have showed me talking more I mean
that's that's also but also it's his
show so he's free to do it's also weird
to compare your show to The Tonight Show
in the 80s oh it's like the peak of
Television ever good point I mean I love
the show it's just a weird comp I don't
know yeah and you know he took Gaff you
see gaffigans Gavin says right a bunch
he goes you say right a lot and the rest
of the episode is him going right right
right it's a montage so you're like yeah
you can edit anything yeah I mean I
think who who hey we got a cat fight and
a dog fight here off cat this is turned
into a we might be a zoo um okay wi
don't play that was in New Orleans
actually this made me feel good at was
that place Kos Kos Kos Kos by myself a
few years ago and this this waitress
from across the restaurant made a beun
she goes your episode's my favorite
episode of the there we go wow that
made me feel good all right a
lot of drinking plus one for you yeah
there you go yeah I saw Nate bergotti
had lunch with Seinfeld and I wrote on
there I didn't know we were allowed to
get a pick I had lunch with him too but
I didn't want to ask for a photo you
used to be hanging with him yeah I was
trying to be cool we text yeah it is
tough to get a pick cuz I've done it I
it definitely ruins the vibe a little
bit totally a pick with yeah well with
you want the pick for the memory but
then once you ask for the pick of course
the show off and the memory but like
there is something about just playing it
cool and yeah I mean them looking at you
as more of a peer than yeah yeah exactly
I was at a restaurant in uh I went on
like a a hinge day like three years ago
and it was was fine and then I went to
eat by myself at little Frankies you
know that a great where you can eat like
400 a.m. and I'm sitting there and I
kind of look behind me and like oh it's
Adam Sandler whoa so then he was eating
he just done an event with his the movie
what was uncut gem so he's like the
whole cast directors and everything was
sitting there and I said hey and he he
goes I go yeah I don't remember you
hosted Letterman once when I was on it
like he hosted Letterman once when I was
on it so s was the guest host for
Letterman yeah yeah yeah and he
remembered yeah and he goes oh yeah no
but it was just but it was a thing where
like pardon me wanted to just get oh I
should grab a picture you're like it's
kind of like you said it's cooler to
just be like hey you're a comic I'm a
comic and uh nice seeing you let's I got
a good pick with Sandler do you that was
a good pick he does seem like he's
pretty friendly about picks he's pretty
cool um he just was like we were we were
doing gigs together I'm going back out
with him this weekend I'm I'm pretty
pumped uh there you go but we uh yeah I
definit was like can I can I snap a
picture of us and he goes yeah yeah I
just he goes the reason I don't post
it's cuz I like people to think like to
not know who's on the show cuz it's like
Sandler and Friends makes it to be a
surprise cuz like look sometimes it's me
but then sometimes you get like Chris
Rock popping you get like you know Spade
or whoever but uh but I get that but
yeah he was he's the nicest dude yeah he
he was really nice and he came like he
at the restaurant he like we talked for
a while and then later he came over and
started talking to asking me about a
tell and stuff oh nice he loves a tell
and Quinn like so much he loves New York
comedy and he and he uh and he talked
about I remember cuz I did the Letterman
thing like on on Netflix the Letterman
sit down thing and he was like let him
in he messaged me he's like isn't he the
king like it's so cool that he just like
he loves comedy so much love to hear
when when I opened for Seinfeld luckily
his bodyguard guy is there and he
snapped a photo so I got one of me and
Jerry to a restaurant but I would have
Lov that lunch photo that Nate got can
you pull that up Matt it's a hell of a
pick Nate baratti I saw it ah we went to
the same place I feel cheated off where
was it Brooklyn Diner in Midtown oh I
used to go he's got his own booth
I remember I walked in and these two
Mexican guys I was like hey I'm here to
meet and they're like we know right here
sir I got there like a half hour
early Matt don't pull up Mia Khalifa
videos what are you
doing there we go look at that boom Oh
my God same restaurant same booth he
wore the same outfit for me he very
happy to to take that picture it's nice
when they look equally happy cuz it's
always weird when you have a eating
grin and they're just like they're like
you know just yeah like all right
totally W Jimmy Fallon coming three
times go relax
Jimbo take a breather go host your
show I can text you my comment hey look
at that I didn't know we were allowed to
get a
pick all right all right now we're
reading you guys are tight still you and
Seinfield yeah I mean we text but I'd
love to get to a a nice steady
consistent
lunch yeah I I almost asked him to do a
redo oh wow and I also almost texted him
about my new special like just to see
like but I I I don't want to be like
exploiting I we your new specials out
now on on you comedy yeah yeah dude I
mean you're one of the best joke writers
really every joke is just like oh thank
you so dry and hilarious and perfect yes
yeah the special was like it's like
pizza where we like I'll have one and
then I ate the whole pie really yeah
it's so funny couldn't turn it off wow
that's nice man Joe what room was that
was that the in Chicago oh the the play
over here did his special yeah yeah nice
good room I'm glad you went to YouTube
route cuz like people sometimes people
don't want to do it but like you need
people to see this it's it's hilarious
you know yeah I mean as I mean I did try
to go the Netflix route and HBO route
and I can name everyone who passed
buy but there is something where like
you can sort of monitor like Netflix at
least at my level and that wouldn't give
me any numbers totally that would it's
doing good on your way
yeah but he'll get more views on YouTube
than HBO I'm calling it right now oh
yeah no question I don't think they push
it on HBO no I kind of I mean I missed
the old days where you got a nice check
for doing a special I mean for me anyway
sure but this is a different kind of
it's like and also I was kind of tired
of most of those jokes anyway so there
you go might as well get rid of them as
Bill bur said a special is just a
commercial for the road yeah you know
come see me buy a ticket look what I can
do right how how's the new stuff it's
slow man slow going same I just like you
know the way it is you get something
you're like oh this works and you feel
like I got work done and you're like I
have a new 22 seconds of material yes
exactly you get one new line out of week
taking a week off you know like I've got
I'm good man I'm on the roll what Gary
Veer said we're on the road over the
weekend and he's like I got three new
bits this week and and he's like and
that'll total 52 seconds exactly exactly
it's just uh but I mean that's how it
starts but I also want to try this thing
which I don't always do where I just
expand every joke I already have like
the ones that I think oh this is a
really solid new joke just how many
other angles can I hit it at because if
you had like 15 20 seconds to each Joke
Man oh yeah that adds up I I saw Goldman
once at the seller and uh he was doing
an old old bit I'm a huge fan from his
first album I was like wow that's an
oldie he goes it's not done I was like
Jesus Christ This Guy's uh meticulous
you got to yeah you got to just tag it
up sometimes I have a bit I have so many
like two 2/3 bits you know like it's
like right there but it's not it's not
good enough to put in something but um
this is the first time I've like taking
my time ever with putting a special out
so I'm not going to tape for till March
but uh I like how that's time for him
like a year and a half it's like only my
seventh special in six
years I know but I I really was like had
was like hustling to get the other ones
like out just out of fear like people
coming out the road but now it's like I
can I feel like I can take a breath a
little bit and it's better for the
comedy but I am still on the road every
week so I'm sick of a lot of these jokes
yeah I mean that I mean that is the I I
almost feel like I know what they're
done when I'm sick of them interesting I
mean that's maybe a little dramatic but
I just feel like sometimes you have like
yeah I can recite this one inside and
out but I do I do hate when I tell a
joke and I'm like am I what am I talking
about I don't even know what I'm saying
right now like kind of autopilot I mean
generally I do a I'm pretty engaged in
the in the show but I there are times
where you're just like you're so locked
into the way of your say something yes
and you're thinking about a restaurant
you're going to later then you're like
oh wait I'm I'm in the middle of this
bit about cats yeah yeah there you go
yeah I saw the special do you uh I mean
do you write differently now than you
did when you were starting out I mean
when I did my first open mic night in
1987 I uh I mean I wrote it out like
handwritten same here like and memorized
it and I'm kind of glad I did that
because it was you know it was like a
real sort of a my first ever set and was
kind of professional looking like like I
wasn't likeone else you know like
looking in a notepad or just being I
mean I seem like I I feel like I did the
prep that other people didn't do but I
did the same I I mean every you know
every so often I'm like I'm gonna sit
down and I'm GNA become a I'm going to
treat this like a day job and I'm work
for two hours a day it's just two hours
a day writing and then just kind of like
I just I'm all over them you know I I've
have an appointment with an ADHD doctor
tomorrow so what really yeah I think cuz
you have trouble focusing yeah I can't
focus I mean what are you kidding I can
focus on stage almost laser focus but as
far as like sit I mean but maybe I it's
just like you've gone so far yeah I've
done very well yeah yeah I mean I
wouldn't you don't need it now no I feel
I I relate to that I my ADD is terrible
I just want to be able to clean my
apartment or something well that's I
mean I people
clean good though I don't yeah what uh
that's fascinating ADHD it's always for
kids I'm also diagnosing myself I'll
I'll let you know tomorrow what happened
is it when people diagnose thems I mean
because I I I was talking to a guy I was
doing crowd work over the weekend and I
was like this guy was like I have sex
Omnia and I was like what the hell is
that he's like when it's like when I'm
asleep but I try to have sex like
sleepwalking but you try to have sex
with the person I was like I don't know
if that's I don't know if that's a thing
but then I looked up it is a thing but
then I asked him have you seen a doctor
he said no I'm like so you're just
diagnosing yourself wow it's a weird
thing to just be like I have it yeah
well other people have told him I guess
I guess yeah I guess I guess it's hard
for a doctor to pick that one out in the
office unless you doze off right he's
got a reverse Cosby he sleeps and then
Fu they could be asleep it could be half
a CA that's good point half a cause yeah
yeah but I mean we do diagnose I mean I
definitely my parents sent me to an add
thing when I was a kid and it was called
like a challenge or something it was and
it was 7 hours mental challenge that's
what it was called it was seven hours
though and it's like that's cruel that's
cruel to do to a child with ad you're
like I can't focus I this is not of it's
not like you walk out of there and
you're like I'm cured you're like that
was painful there no book on
tape on ADHD and uh or audiobook I don't
guess they call them books on scroll on
Instagram and then just even that you're
like there's chapters like how do you
expect me to get through this chapter
even listening to it when it's about not
being able to focus and you're like in
these Minor Details good point you need
treats like being an animal they need us
treats right like little you treat
yourself like if
you let's say do a great show or
something or or get something
finished coil a good drink good meal
couple cookies yeah yeah yeah you got to
do it but I can't imagine you sedated
really well you couldn't some already
boring is that what you're saying well
I'm just saying you're you're a lowkey
guy if you were sedated I you'd
disappear
uh but what do you mean sedated on what
well like if you take ADHD the opposite
of I think it focuses you oh it brings
you up like uppers yeah if I take a if I
take like a you know an add Med like a
conera or something I'm I can bang out I
should take it more I can bang so many
jokes ED medication I've taken it before
I I I don't have that many so I use it
very you know yeah that's kind of what I
want from this doctor is just like
something where like right now I feel
like I want to be focused not like every
day three times a day it's like roids I
mean it's literally It's Kind it's like
steroids in baseball like we're kind of
cheating a little bit by taking it but
also a lot of people don't have this but
if you I think feel like if you do have
it it would still help I've heard people
say the opposite but I think it just
focuses I think
ADHD helps us do what we need to I mean
we're benefiting from because our mind
wanders our mind wanders also pinpoint
stuff quicker than other people but it
also hurts us yeah yeah deded sword I
saw you when I was a young comic I
remember seeing Todd in a star Buck
writing and I was writing that wasn't me
that definitely wasn't first Starbucks
new second writing new you it was
definitely maybe it was I there could
have been star there was a time I used
to go to Star but I mean I remember just
going there and seeing you and being
like oh Todd's like you know that's
that's what you want to see Comics you
like is that they're they're still
putting in the work you know right oh I
love that yeah it's weird you're from
Florida I'm I mean I was born in New
York but I I started comedy in Florida I
lived in Florida for like 15 years wow
is that hell uh I mean it's my who knows
it's like the Forma of year so probably
would have been hell anywhere but true
true when you're young shy guy it's just
Florida's got a interesting alumni it's
like Bert ker oh is he from Florida TSH
yeah he's Tampa rean Carrot Top I
started with Carrot Top and and Larry
the Cable Guy are you still friendly
with them no I mean I'm not feuding with
them but I just yeah I don't I mean I'm
sure I could get in touch with either of
them if I heard someone want on
carrat top and you were like who else
you kind of defended him and I I kind
and I liked it I like that you I was
like all right like I just like
contrarian takes and it's like it became
hip to on katop yeah he's just like
oh well like I saw some
um Tik Tok video today actually got the
worst Comics ever and there the five and
I'm not going to mention their names but
it was like this is a list from 2008
right like just who you could guess have
been like it's just I don't I don't know
it's just like car especially comedy
lists are annoying good or bad bad
especially it's when it's like an
amateur take it when I hear an when I
like overhear open micers on
Pros even as an open micer it bothered
me oh yeah I've had I've had that where
you're like your opening act is
on the MC it's like I don't know either
of you
guys I kind of don't want to hear this
it's awkward I don't want you to like
it's like you're not ingratiating
yourself with me by being shitty to a
guy who's on the show with us yeah I
think it's kind of a young comic thing
though they they they're so insecure
they're so new that they have to feel
better by on everyone else and
you do need a blow off steam but I it
still bugged me a little bit and we did
it but it still bugged me I mean it's
well I always feel like there's I
mean I definitely can talk and if
these mics are off and and that guy left
and the cat left now don't leave the
kste I would uh you know then you know
sitting up this upstairs at the celery
like what the that should be the
podcast is just the mic's the mic's off
that's the name of the podcast blow up
and you're like you know who
sucks that's the whole episode
definitely I can do plenty of that and I
can't wait to do it once this show's
over from this very seat Well I was at
skankfest not bragging but Ari of course
had this great idea at the end to do a
show no phones couple comics on stage
behind a table and the audience yells
out a comic and they have to trash them
but like real trashing not like oh
Matt re's annoying it was like real
and it got ugly I mean it was too real
really I mean I was I was in the crowd
just glued to my seat it was
entertaining as hell but they were
saying stuff where you're like you know
these guys people the audience can just
remember this and then tweet it or
whatever yeah I love AR I don't love
that it was wild I don't love the idea
of like also it feels a little bit like
turn Cody to me like it should be I
don't know thing yeah I remember hearing
Stan hope once say like someone went up
to him and uh and on Dane Cook to
him and he goes I like danne better than
you and I do kind of like I have no
problem with the audience M but I don't
like when they try to ingratiate thems
by on a peer of ours I don't
yeah I've had that happen or they'll
even do it like you you do a show at
like a showcase show and they're like
that guy before you wasn't good oh my
friend I
know I've known for 22 years yeah you
didn't like him right it's just I mean I
guess they're trying to make it sound
like you're you're you stood out but you
could say that in a way without what was
the deal with the guy before you I don't
know yeah I guess you didn't like him
that's fine I could have been that guy
and I've been that guy to the other to a
million people the people have a weird
instinct to rate everything like I
watched people come out of the comedy s
they go the third guy was great he was
the best one second guy sucked third guy
fourth guy competition shows play well
that's why they always try to make us
compete people want to pick a winner
mind they really do but this is
entertain Hyman this isn't a sport right
yeah and it's subjective like you might
relate more to this lady cuz you're a
lady and then you might relate more you
know people pick their guy or their G
how was Larry the Cable Guy out of the
gate what was that like he actually
drove me to my I think my one of my
first paid gigs like Camaro or Firebird
to Ron bennington's Club
benon yeah Ron benington saw my first
ever appearance as a comic Dan Whitney
and Dan Whitney yeah we on the open mic
scene and and you know and then I guess
after I left Florida he used to call
into this radio station Larry the
Campell guy the rest is history yeah
that you know I feel like there's comedy
for everyone like this it might not be
you know there's people like like we're
going back to katop was like he's doing
a goofy show that's kind of fun I
probably I would like to see would love
to see it i' probably love every second
of it and just like he's not pretending
he's you know political he's just making
you laugh yeah yeah and he's a nice guy
think the bitterness comes to when
people who think that they should be
further than him but what they fail to
realize is he's doing a different thing
it's a different he's in Vegas Yes move
to Vegas you want you know what I mean
like I sure as would want to live
there go crazy God no yeah that
residency I think there's also that
thing that people who are like they go
to more than 10 comedy shows and they're
like I have a different level of inside
you know like I get it like I remember
there was a guy in in
Melbourne during the festival who the
comment section started basically a
review column within the comment SE I go
to a lot of shows and this like that you
could be have terrible taste and go to a
lot of shows yeah also you could go to a
lot of shitty shows CU you you have bad
taste also there could be hacky comic
there's also hacky takes like oh Dane
Cook sucks and you're like have you ever
listened you just heard someone else say
that yeah exctly you know but that's the
cool he was the cool guy to hate for a
while that's the thing when you become
incredibly successful it becomes a cool
thing to on the person but like
they had love him or hate him they have
something to get to that level you and
also did you work as hard as that person
nope Dan on you know the standup and the
business end undeniably worked hard oh
yeah Myspace baby forgot about
myspace old school so you like I
remember back in the day you do panel on
Conan all the time how many of those did
you do I mean I think I did Conan I mean
I hate to know I do know
exactly I think it was 18 times woo
oh that's stand up and panels oh yeah
yeah I I miss doing Conan God oh Conan
was the number one that was just like
really like I felt you feel like you're
in Show Business you know like it's fun
doing these clubs and everything but
then you just like your cars coming at
5:43 5:45 uh you're going to be in
dressing room next to Martha Stewart
okay who is who are some of the craziest
guests you were on with Martha Stewart
was right next to me what's the guy did
you talk to her no I didn't talk to you
um Val Kilmer
wow who's the guy Kilmer rules the best
Bruce Stern who's the other guy
Daniel Stern no he Howard Donald
southernland oh another Legend he was on
but then I remember like Al Roker was on
once and he he like made a Bel line to
say hi to me like he's like oh hey he
saying who the other guest recogniz just
being like a sweetheart but um yeah but
yeah and I remember yeah when you on
with bouran on one of them I was on uh
um Seth Meer show with bour oh that's a
good one you talk to him right it's
weird because I did you get the photo no
he
he I saw that he followed me on Twitter
like a few years prior to that and I and
then I I think I was on I was on a
flight with him from Austin and then I I
sent him a direct message inviting him
to my shows and he thanked me said I
don't know if I can make that then I
sent him like my special he's like oh
I'll check it out thanks and then I I
mean sounds like a this is like three
direct messages in like eight years no
so it wasn't like I wasn't hounding them
and that's why he ended it but uh these
messages I can't take it but then I said
hey we're on Seth Meer show together and
he goes oh I can't wait and then he he
kind of just came in the dressing room
said Hi and then left like there was no
conversation he was nice but I've heard
he's very he was very shy actually M 65
I heard yeah he's yeah he was he was the
best yeah he was cool cool guy that was
pretty devastating I got to ask you
about this oh so you've called in the
Letterman he called me wait you got to
pull this up there pet up this it's on
YouTube put I this get enough even
though I promoted the hell out of this I
came across this on accident and I was
like why is this not a thing yeah there
it is yeah I remember this that can't be
1982 can it yeah what from someone named
Todd Raz I'm guessing that's just a
nickname his last name is Barry from
tamarak Florida here's the situation I
do an unbelievable impression of Paul
schaer here are the options a fly me to
New York pay for everything and I'll do
the impression on your
show yeah
right or call me and I'll do it over the
phone so go ahead Dave pick either A or
B either way I'm sure it will turn out
to be a real Nifty gig
uh it was a tough choice Todd but I've
selected option b let's call
this this is amazing yeah were you
bricks calling somewhere yeah I
kind of was yeah and they call to say
we're doing yeah yeah but that's it wow
this this is late night in the80s this
is huge no this is going to be the first
yeah okay Todd Barry apparently a man
with a lot of time on his
hands doing soon an impression of our
own musical director Mr Paul Schaefer
we're waiting for that first hello well
hello Todd how are you uh is this Todd
yes Todd my name is David Letterman I'm
calling from New York City how are you
sir I'm all right right where are you
now Todd I'm in Florida
uh-huh
killing what were you 11 sounds just
like doesn't it uh what what particular
City Todd um it's tamarak tamarak is it
near a larger community near for laud oh
well that gives us generally an idea
it's a nice area of the country there uh
I noticed Todd the phone didn't ring and
you just picked it up did it ring there
yeah that's the way that thing works oh
that's the way they work
work that's great you're singing with
the king I can't believe I said that gee
uh Todd I'd love to go on talking with
you but I understand you do an
impression of Mr Paul sh this weird gets
it's unreal Dave okay it's unreal Dave
yeah Dave yeah Dave it's unreal Dave I
mean it's cuckoo groovy Dave I mean I'm
peeking right now
Dave me is it is it not in here it's
just me
Dave back to you Dave okay thank you
very much very nice Todd thank
you
wow I mean did you and there was a
followup with you oh really did you ever
mention this to him when you did a show
I tried to I just never really asserted
it but I didn't try hard enough to tell
him about it
but this was two years later I feel much
better thank you very much uh it's
getting very close to the gala Gaya
second anniversary of my appearance on
your show that's right May 27th 1982 was
the day I BL your viewer mail segment
with my Paul Schaefer impression here
are your options a fly me to New York
and pay for everything or B call me and
we'll celebrate by phone so go ahead
Dave Pick A or B either way I'm sure it
will turn out to be the ultimate in Keen
your friend for life Todd Barry tamarak
Florida uh well Todd thank you very much
for the letter and uh I'm sorry to say
that if your choices are only A and B
then I'm not really sure there's any
anything we can do oh wait a minute
excuse me just a minute see just forget
about me I've already got more than I
deserve oh okay fine thank
you very wow that would keep me
going for 10 years yeah uh Dear Dave all
right wow that is pretty great yeah you
got a you got a good zing on him I did I
I can't believe I did that man just kind
of just and also it's just weird cuz he
didn't hear the phone ring but it did
ring so that's that's I guess it's I
thought I heard a ring too yeah it did
you could hear it wow that is an
18-year-old I would be running around
the house in excitement I hate
to reveal my Edge bits over 40 years ago
ah it was a different time 40
approximately 40 years ago
Jesus it's all over for me man also your
Comedy Central half hour which one you
did two of them yeah oh maybe I remember
I still remember the joke you say the
opening joke I know what you guys are
thinking uh the the watch joke oh yeah
yeah what How's It Go Again what was it
say you say like oh uh Todd this is your
second Comedy Central special but you're
wearing the same watch and you go I'll
tell you what's new five of the next 30
minutes you're going to see such a great
way to open a special oh than you yeah
that was fun those were you old albums
man I me we used to listen to All medium
energy yeah falling off the bone medium
energy like that was when albums like to
me I love consuming comedy that way I
mean taking a walk my Alum comes out
this Thursday actually the ALB version
of my special there you go I I think
Todd is like perfect certain comics with
Just Killer jokes are perfect for that
Medium where you have like guy like Todd
or David tell or Hedberg like yes jokes
like that where you're just like these
are this is a perfect thing to listen to
in a car on the walk cuz cuz they're
just hard jokes 100% And they go into
your brain better when you just listen
you know you're walking it I feel like
you connect with it more you hear the
laugh i' almost I think I'd almost
rather watch listen to an album of
that's what I'm saying I don't know
that's how I got into it really it's
like it's like albums like you or like
you know grock or or all those people we
talked about that's how we watched him
right oh yeah well Rock I was HBO and
Carlin a lot of HBO but but his stuff
worked well audio too his voice and his
jokes I mean true it worked it
translated too I think yeah I would just
put them on like a the way you put on a
podcast in the house and clean or
whatever loved them I used to throw in
like early years like you forget how to
write you forget how to write a bit and
you're like let me just listen to bits
for a while like hear like other
people's and then you were like oh yeah
that's how I write jokes you know but
like uh you you throw on Pandora and you
get like so many different comic voices
yeah it is interesting to hear what
people can get away with and like oh
they that they got away with like I saw
Doug Stan hope at Carolines on Mother's
Day open with a joke about his mother's
suicide wow I was like at Carolines
which is very touristy so it wasn't all
his dieh hard fans it was just like man
you can do you can do that that's an
incredible bit where he talks it's an
assisted suicide assisted suicide great
bit yeah he he is like they throw on the
word fearless and comedy a lot but like
Doug is like truly will he'll say
that is pretty incredible and he doesn't
really get like attacked for saying
anything you know problematic but he's
also the last guy who would stop himself
from saying something that's true yeah I
don't think they would ever expect an
apology from him I think he goes in it's
the people that kind of like dip their
toe in that get in trouble I think Doug
is so Unapologetic yeah yeah kind of
lives outside the system in a while
exactly also are they going to like not
allow him to live in like some outskirt
of Arizona Arizona but it's like yelling
at a hobo like hey that was
inappropriate he's like what are you
going to do I got I got nothing going on
not the Doug has nothing going on but
but he gets away with it I think with I
think the drugs and alcohol help where
he's just kind of like this dude who's
is you said outside the system and
showing up you know he's had a few
already and uh yeah I mean I remember
listening he's another dude whose albums
I would listen to and just be like holy
this dude just goes for it no
refunds is amazing and uh what's the one
something to take the edge off oh yeah
yeah yeah all those dead beat Heroes
yeah he's one of the few guys who I
would actually when he came to New York
I would go watch him really yeah and sit
there I mean guest list but
um that's not big for crazy I didn't
throw down for it but tell says
he's his favorite comic yeah he's great
I saw oh sorry I saw tell Carolines and
Doug was in the back watching no wait
Doug was on stage of Carolines David
walked in and Doug stopped mid bit and
goes Dave what are you doing here he
goes I heard a white voice coming out of
Carolines I had to see who it was and
that
killed damn well who were guys like
early on cuz I know you were you know
like a '90s New York guy like that great
generation of comics were there dudes
that you would sit down and write bits
like bounce bits with in the dine orever
no no I mean I didn't I never I've done
that occasionally with people I think
think I've even done with you but I've
never had like a every Monday we meet at
this diner for so I New York not really
I mean a little I've done it a little
with Joe
Zimmerman um new special new special
funny guy hey it's not about him right
now yeah he very funny um but I I
haven't yeah I mean I guess I've gotten
tags and stuff from people who happen to
be watching but yeah I haven't done a
lot and there's stuff people all bounce
off of on the phone but I generally
just do it myself yeah but I do think
there's definitely like I would want to
do more just like meeting up and
bouncing bits because I think it is
helpful oh yeah and it's not like having
someone to write for you but it it just
gets you talking it out with someone who
knows and reading their face just like
delivering it to a person reading their
face and kind of being like huh okay
where am I going right here where am I
going wrong am I missing something
obvious yeah I don't I don't expect
someone else to do my ACT I want to
write my jokes sure um even saying it
out loud to a person person helps it
kind of makes you hear how it sounds I
always think I'm going to you know I
sometimes go well I I work I write on
stage that's what I tell people mainly
which when they ask about my writing
which is true but I also feel you write
on stage yeah huh really you feel very
page to Stage no definitely no
definitely r on stage that's so I would
never guess that really yeah so you
thought like all those my epic bits were
like yeah of course that was
typing no I of course Ty oh really no
it's on stage I think of bits and you're
like okay so you have a bit like uh let
me think of an example of like a Todd
bit like a classic Todd like uh you saw
a guy masturbating in front of an ATM
machine and you thought you know sure
there are times when I look at my
checking account and I'm there's a
little more than oh that's great and you
want to celebrate and you want to cele
yeah so that you came up with that on
the fly on stage um I don't remember I
that was a while ago I may have done
more writing writing back then but I
yeah I mean after a few I mean it's not
like out of the gate they work like but
you just had a nugget yeah you just kind
of like oh and then you add this a
couple of words and then you do it again
and I mean it takes forever the wine one
the wine one what was so you have the
wine bit in your new special about how
the the bottle is the second most
expensive the second most expensive
bottle or second cheapest bottle rather
is the one that they mark up the most
right so like how do like can you take
us through the process of writing a joke
like that well I heard that someone I
heard that somewhere and it seemed to
make sense that
the the most marked up I wine on a
Restaurant's menu is the second cheapest
because a guy will be on a date I'm I'm
doing the bed basically the bit guy a
day doesn't want to buy the cheapest
wine so he picks the second cheapest and
then gets
destroyed so then I just talked it
through and actually Phil gave me a one
of the lines I shouldn't credit Phil
with
anything comedy wise but uh yeah he kind
of gave me the one of one of the big
laughs in it actually but uh but yeah so
I just talked it through and then
eventually it once you get it into where
it's like everything works
supposedly cuz there's there's times I'm
sure you know where you like have a bit
and you're
like oh
totally takes so long just like I got to
fix that little part right there yes yes
and it's like a yeah um so yeah just
over repeating it over and over again is
that you write your stuff out completely
both you guys not completely if it's a
story I can't if a story I kind of have
to listen and just memorize but uh but
there's still beats that I write down
and start I'm like get to this line get
to this line get like almost like like
checkpoints in the story that I'm trying
to get to same but then for a bit I I'm
pretty much uh I have word docs full of
just yeah almost every joke written out
word for word I have bullet points I
definitely have bullet points I the
bullet and I will sometimes go I'm going
to just pretend I'm writing this like
it's you know I'll write it out and
they'll do that but I've also had the
reverse where like a TV shows can you
send us a transcript of your act or
you're s then you do it and you're like
I I don't even know how to punctuate
this yes none of this seems funny
they're going to read this and hate it I
should say that yeah that annoys the
of me even though I write most of
the jokes down cuz for whatever reason
once it starts working I just lose track
of it you know but like yeah also it's
hard to type it out in your right that's
so I will type it to some degree but
then I also a lot of the typing is also
just the start and the finish I just
need know where it end up but like I had
a bit idea the other day it's like a new
idea but true story got shitfaced and I
go home and I'm
on I I go on for whatever reason like
cancer Charities are popping up like
Children's Cancer and I got so upset
that I made I made a pretty big donation
I was like cancer I woke up the
next day and you I was like well that's
a bit more than I would have donated you
know which like it's a weird moment cuz
like you can't the angle at the end of
the angle I'm like I think it's like you
can't really call AMX fraud department
like some stole my card and I
guess he really wants a cure but like
that's a bit that I don't think I could
write down I needed to like say it
because it's such a weird uh typing up a
bit like that there's a fine line
between like you know it has to sound
conversational too and that's I think
the struggle for just writing bits but
that bit is great too because you do you
do uh philanthropy when you're drunk
most guys do worse things you do better
things cuz you're even like I wouldn't
have given this much you when you're
drunk you would have you done the thing
where you call the charity up and go
listen I got a a little awkward
situation look I want to help but not
that much right 250 I'm fine with
250 but 2,000 I don't know I was I was
drunk to me if you have the premise and
the ending I feel a lot better going on
stage really yeah the end the end line
like a nice pop at the end to tie it all
up yeah cuz then you can you can fish a
little bit exactly you can kind of play
with the middle and you know you have a
like a parachute at the end it's like
it's like you know when you're going to
get laate on a date you can kind of Be
Yourself yes yes I heard Pete Holmes
said he goes really dirty when a joke is
new because he's he's nervous so he's he
can get the laughs
there or and then Bill bur said when
he's doing a new hour he kind of hacks
it up a little just because he's like I
got to get through it it's not there yet
see I think I don't always follow this
but I think opening if you're doing a 10
minutes at somewhere 15 minutes opening
with the new stuff is a good thing to do
Ted said the same thing did he Ted
Alexandro sto that from me
but um yeah I guess I just feel like you
ride that wave of like being appla the
Applause comes on you get here's Mark
and then you just go and if your first
three things don't if they work then you
got your other just locked and
loaded but if they don't work then you
just ease into the other stuff that
works interesting I think it works when
you have your audience I think if you're
doing that coming up as a comic they
might just turn on you exactly I
remember hearing Ted say that as a young
comic and then doing that like the comic
strip and they're like this guy you
know there's always that thing now where
you do a bunch of you know a stuff and
then you try the new one and it's just
such a huge drop off oh yeah I mean I
guess at that point you can go hey that
one didn't work I mean we can get away
with things other people who make
mistakes at their job can't do but we go
up but yeah try to when you're
air traffic controller
but got someone I feel like that's
pretty good I don't know that's fun but
also uh I hear what you're saying
especially I think if it's like a
topical bit it's great to open with cuz
they're like oh he's writing that's
a new bit yeah and you get a 20% boost I
think on topical you get you do a Taylor
Swift joke or something like at it's
like it's an extra bump or something
like that you know and it show like if
you do jokes about the town first of all
they love that they're like oh my God
he's telling us about our town even
though the joke might be a eh like a c
they're on board I would notice opening
for dve tell whatever City he was in he
would be like he would like praise them
he'd be like Ann Arbor Michigan you guys
know how to
party
manipul you got to do that you gotta
like you got cuz they feel when you're
pumped to be there they're pumped to be
there totally you can't just walk up and
be like I was at the bank you got to say
hello you got to show where you know
where you are some guys would do that
though I mean I I remember watching old
clips of robbert shimel I feel like he
never said hey what's up he would just
like he would always just be like so a
guy does this
open a bit you know I kind of like that
I mean I'm I kind of like I don't like
when the a comic goes let's hear it for
your MC it's like the guys the MC's
getting the Applause I completely agree
getting their Applause you don't and
just s a brow beating people
with applaud kind like Make some noise I
do it if I'm on the road cuz I bring
Gary with me and I want them to like
follow him social media I want them to
or
maybe go hey let's hear it again from my
but I feel like just I don't and I don't
like how how you guys do tonight I hate
that it seems all unnecessary and just
like start doing what you do I mean yeah
what's the purpose is it I guess I think
it resets kind of yeah I get that you
have to do something if there's a like a
crazy energy change like if you're
following some high energy guy you have
to address it somehow but you can do it
in a more clever way than hey you know
yeah yeah well yeah I mean I'm not I get
it you know you walk out there you're
greeting people how's it going but
but I don't know just one the one with
let's hear it for because if they see
seven comics and they're let's hear it
for the MC they all do it like they the
guy's not no one's he's not being
deprived of Applause he walked out to
Applause he's going to walk off to
Applause yeah he just said your name you
know he's you know it's not like some we
don't have to applaud the MC do we also
with those seven comic lineups or
wherever how many they put up at the
seller I'm always nervous I'm at the end
if I'm like doing some topical bit it's
been hit eight times that's why like I
don't I basically don't allow guest sets
in my shows same
cuz mainly because I just want to get
out there like I have my opener do 15
minutes one opener for the most part you
know sometimes you go we have a local
guy okay let them do five and then but I
want to get out there but also like yeah
premises can get burned and you're like
and even premises I mean I did a show
Once I used to do this joke about this
Walgreens in Chicago I oh the rating
like the reviews on it no no it was
about this it used to be in a converted
bank and I don't remember how the joke
went but a guy went on before me did a
joke about that Walgreens no way yeah it
was a different joke it's just like and
then you have to go out they go well
this is weird
[Laughter]
people Bobby did a joke about the
Walgreens and Lincoln in uh Wicker Park
and now I'm going to do one and neither
of us were in Chicago at the time
Oh
weird how about uh what about this this
must have been page to
Stage hey I saw a guy with a neck tattoo
whenever I see that I always think you
forgot to not do that God that one makes
me cringe for I love that line love that
joke know I know that's a great joke
guess it's just hard to listen to Old I
feel Mark if someone pulled up bits off
your like a first album you'd probably
cringe too I guess true true let's do
something off my special all right all
right but I honestly don't remember if I
wrote that out or I probably I think
about that line once a week I definitely
thought of that and then wrote it out
but I don't but forgot to not was a a
sentence I'd never heard before I
thought that was well written yeah
that's that would be like a great piece
of movie dialogue but it's so like deep
in your character I mean you when I say
her character but
like um what's he looking up I don't
know I thought you going to go to his
Instagram or something and pull up a bit
clips from the new special domestic we
rarely like I feel like this almost
started as a a joke podcast and we don't
we got away from that a little bit but
you're a dude that I I love to go into
these with you know oh yeah you got a
clip up there oh there's one there's one
yeah which one's this glad we're eating
out again I've had some great exchanges
with waiters and waitresses over here
act with waer at an Italian restaurant
in New York City not too long ago hi is
it possible to get a decaf espresso
you're the
[Laughter]
worse
okay
I don't mean to be all lawyerly but that
was a yes or no
question but if you want to go with
you're the worst that works
fine anyway give me a Decap espresso
with big spoon of ketchup
in now I'm really
bad it's brilliant stuff good
stuff important important stuff it's got
to be rough to watch this no he's this
is the one he's probably most happy with
do really good before the pandemic
started taking a pilates class oh that's
a good one consisted of me and three
women who knew how to do
Pilates the instructor always had to
make adjustments you're like all right
ladies let's do that thing when we hang
from a bar and do jumping jacks and
situps at the same time good one Todd
here's some
crayons crayons is that is that hack won
you mark up the wall for me to
crayons draw an owl for
me big owl with a lot of
detail all right ladies we're going to
stand on our hands and put 100 lb
weights on the balls of your feet Todd I
don't know download a Scrabble
app Clean too leave yeah why you
leave I like that idea
best walking's good exercise walk on out
air yes I see your T-shirt it says
iHeart
Pilates
hit the road hit the road that's kind of
really well shot too yeah it looks great
I uh I tagged my Pilates instructor on
that exciting oh nice or I yeah well I
think I sent it to her but uh do you go
to Pilates a lot not no I haven't I used
I was going pre- pandemic but what's
great about your bits is you can tell it
all happened yeah it's not like a Hassan
Manaj like went there it's just uh like
the waiter saying you're the worst I'm
like that definitely happened and you
can name the I'd like to I'd like to
hear Todd meets H son you know oh guy
sent me some uh Anthrax
[Laughter]
recently that's good yeah man but it's
true you know what it is you take
mundane and make it so damn
relatable and so funny I mean it's like
everyday stuff where you're like I I
love bits like this where you're like
well that's not a bit and then you see
you do it you're like oh that's a bit
you just open up possibilities right
love when Comics do that you Brian
Regan's great at that where so great all
right this premise I could I probably
could have thought of this premise and
then he just like 10 minutes of I know
hilarious yeah and no one he's got
his own that wobble and everything he's
got his own way of delivering it which a
lot of that funny man funny guy a legend
yeah we we we're supposed to have him on
here too right is he still going to come
on he's going to drink us under the
table oh yeah he'll put him back but you
also choose good words that old joke
about uh the guy's like I love Coke but
I hate Pepsi and you're like oh wow so
you love this thing and hate this thing
that's the exact same thing as this
thing with a fervor I don't know I
remember you said f so funny cuz last
night Colin Quinn got furious at Matt
Richards for drinking Pepsi and he was
drinking Coke that's why the jokes are
relatable that was such a great I'm like
that is a true thing like we watched his
joke play out yes
fervor yeah I for I I remember that joke
I don't remember the the wording but I
remember so many of your jokes man
there're some of the most quotable jokes
uh I mean you did a letterman say
remember you have a joke where you say I
was just in uh in Spain very aggressive
prostitutes in Barcelona yeah I mean
just that start to a joke is funny to me
aggressive prostitute line if if you're
this uh if you're this aggressive in the
streets what's going to happen when we
get back to the youth
host that's a great bit yeah you're
going to knock me off that top
bunk there a tag I mean that's a great
bit and uh those letter like late night
sets were tough I mean it's crazy to
think that's a pretty edgy late night
bit yeah yeah I mean I was yeah was I
don't think you could say prostitutes
anymore but uh but yeah that was yeah
they I kind of pushed it a little bit I
I guess I don't pushed it but it's
surprised never knew what they were
going to let you do and what they would
hassle you with but how about the bit
there's another great word choice when
you were hooking up with a girl and she
was like I don't like that kind of
condom and you're like this is a bad
time to Show brand loyalty brand loyalty
that's great that's for my first that's
an old top bit old old you could
probably dig up my first Conan if you
want to watch could we really I would
love to see a bit from it at least give
me a bit and I want to see what you look
like I yeah you're doing the rounds look
at you you're hitting all the pods yeah
no these are it's older oh that's an old
one there whoa look at that oh I
remember you did the Chris is that the
Chris uh what's his name the Chris
odonnell yeah yeah yeah is that that one
yeah that was a pretty funny one what
happened to that guy I think you have to
look on Conan's website to find
the he has a website I think he's
working I think dude like that just
worked forever on some like CBS show who
don't watch Chris oh yeah you're
probably right yeah I don't know I think
he's working he's on like Miami Vice 8
well even think about that guy you know
you know that actor William Peterson
he's like richer than he ever would have
been if he just became a movie CSI and
totally wow he got the cover
melany by the way Kanye's back you see
that oh my God yeah really is he Adidas
resigned
him wow that's young is that young
Millen that's a great Millan set by the
way oh my God he's a child there I saw
that in New Orleans and it was blown
away who's that guy in the middle old
Conan really he threw up everybody he
threw up a lot of he gave Comics a lot
of love oh yeah first credit yeah yeah
yeah I think so 29 that was my first one
too yeah that was a big deal I did uh I
remember you dabbed your forehead with
his tie yes yes and he was not pleased
no I didn't love it yeah he said you're
a psyo or something it was on
uh no it's 19 it was definitely on the
co Team Coco we don't have to find it
you had you had a really great roast set
who who Patrice O'Neal I mean Chevy
Chase and Patrice o' Neil the Chevy
Chase one do you remember any of the
Chevy Chase lines yeah I mean the one
that lot of people talked about it was
like people you know I told people I was
roasting Chevy Chase they said that's
like shooting fish in the barrel and I
it's actually as easy as standing near a
fish in a back something like that being
somewhere was that night Awkward as hell
um didn't he just hates yeah that was he
he yeah was it was awkward not
necessarily like where I was
uncomfortable it was just it's clear
that it just didn't have the because he
just wasn't taking the jokes the way
someone wrot if you agree to a Roose
you're supposed to just how
whatever you but it wasn't his
friends that I feel like I didn't know
him they got if they had me in there
like I met him after I roasted him wow
that's weird how was he he I just shook
his hand but he he was sort of nice to
me when he went up after like he kind of
he kind I think I caught him laughing oh
god look how cute come on the the Chevy
thing was so weird to me because I from
what I heard that's the night he found
out a lot of people didn't like him oh
there it is oh yeah I think oh know it
if you're looking to level up your home
with zero effort displate has you
covered displate creates awesome metal
posters that takes just 20 seconds to
install and won't damage your walls with
licensed designs from Brands like Star
Wars Marvel and League of Legends your
flimsy Blockbuster posters from high
school are getting a serious upgrade
submit your own artwork to be turned
into a display for Something Completely
personalized you can do all kinds of
cool stuff with this they have a lot of
Classics a lot of cool movies we had the
back to school one which I love love
Dangerfield as you guys know your poster
comes with everything you need to hang
immediately just pop the included magnet
on your wall stick your display to it
and you're all set save up to 40% off
when you click the link in our
description and get you ready to hang
Art discount will be automatically
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use the code drunk when you
visit display.com that's display.com
code drunk or click the link in her show
notes hey hey folks we might be drunk is
brought to you by beam there's nothing
you need more than a good night sleep
sleeping less than six to seven hours
per night is linked to reduced white
blood cell count weight gain and poor
mental health you got that right if
you're sick of counting sheep it's time
to try beam dream the healthy hot cocoa
for Sleep woo baby I need some sleep and
this really helps I love a good night's
sleep I can't podcast I can't do
anything without it it's uh it's it's
it's hell all I got to do is think thank
you love that beam thank you just mix
beam dream in hot water milk stir or
froth and enjoy before bedtime and he
you got to do it folks who doesn't love
hot cocoa also today our listeners get a
special discount on beam's dream powder
their bestselling healthy hot cocoa for
sleep with no added sugar now available
in delicious flavors like sea salt
caramel cinnamon cocoa and chocolate
peanut butter better sleep is never
tasted so good a recent clinical study
revealed dream help 93% of users wake up
feeling more refreshed and 93% reported
that dream helped them get a more
restful night sleep get on it if you
want to try beam's bestselling dream
powder get up to 40% off for a limited
time when you go to shop
beam.com drunk and use code drunk at
checkout that's shop
bam.com drunk and use code drunk for up
to 40% off get some beam yeah that's is
what
year3 thanks a lot thanks guys only 11
years of the phone call listening the
radio today I was um I keep playing this
Michael Bolton guy
I can't stand this guy I remember the
first time I heard Michael Bolton my
immediate reaction was oh man I owe
Barry Manalo an
[Music]
apology the band was like how h no mik
this guy is much worse he is mucho Del
woro but there was a concert recently in
New York City it's the truth Simon and
gar funcle followed by Paul son Simon
and gar funcle then Paul son this must
have been a great phone call for Art
Garfunkle to
receive hey Art it's Paul good news and
bad news good news I got us a gig bad
news we're opening for
me yeah and you got to share a dressing
room with Lady Smith black
momazo it's going to be a tight fit
there's 23 of
them but the big thing in music now in
record stores are these boxed sets have
you seen these boxed sets this all the
albums by one artist in a box who were
these for there's a guy standing going
for God I've never owned anything by the
oakd
boys I think it's time I owned
everything by the
oakd it's a good let me see that wow
great point I remember that joke I don't
remember that I think that was one and a
half hours I think remember the fugazi
this thing is heavy 27 compact discs hey
it's only
$500 includes a hip-hop remix of
elvir gety
uper but I did a little shopping
recently I did bought a walk that is a
great thing to have a walk with a walk
in the privacy of your own home you can
create your own mediocre Chinese
food for 50 cents less than ordering
takeout I'm standing over going oh yeah
I'm glad I'm making this stuff
myself cuz those restaurants in
Chinatown just don't make hot dog fried
rice the way I
like pause it for a sec you had you were
exactly the same you had it immediately
the your voice huh but ites seem like my
voice sounds almost different like I'm a
boy in this one well younger yeah voice
changes as you get older but the rhythm
is is so you even now it's kind of
impressive what's with that jacket what
is oh it's brutal the way I was dressed
the sleeves chutting I saw that like the
green sleeve what is that patch on the
on the left side a dog it's a borso I
bought or the thrift store oh okay got
it that was do you remember who was on
that episode with you I do was it was a
bunch of guests it was this guy actor
Peter rert you remember him yes great
you know him he's from Animal House was
four gu I think it was me and he's in
the mask he's in a ton of you know
this guy oh that guy Carol Al I don't
know yeah wait how do we know where's
she from again she's a model and then
there was one other I was like cuz I
remember they had four is there any way
you could see who was on that episode
holy moly she's hot kind of milfy yeah
yeah oh yeah she looks looks familiar
Carol Alt alt
comedy wow we're going deep diving here
well this season one of Conan
wow you were also and Larry Sanders oh
that's right I got that from that set
actually
whoa that was when you could still get
stuff from a late night set Nicole
edgert oh Don Martin that's right and
then of course they leave me out of the
oh that sucks um
damn you got someone saw you on this
like you should chandling saw me oh W I
submitted a tape and he's like you got
the part look cool to you what he was
really cool like like he did something
that I mean I've talked about it before
on on one of my many podcast appearances
but uh he like he came over to give me a
note on my something with the line I was
doing and he just said he goes only if
you think this is funny and then he
presented his note what a guy just like
I could have said no thank no I'm good
thanks like it's I was like it's your
show I'll do it any way you want me to
do it yeah but yeah I thought that was
really respectful and and also smart I
mean yeah you guys ran the whole show
back then it was like that that that was
a hot bed of young janin and uh Sarah
Silverman's and Bob Odin Kirks yeah that
was a fun time Jay Moore was young yeah
I forgot he was on it oh yeah Jay Moore
was on Shanley sers wasn't he I thought
he was in the writer room I don't no
that was uh Jeremy Piven oh PIV
sorry but uh yeah he was great on Larry
Sanders that was I mean it was one of
the best shows ever I love it it was
classic I mean that was uh some of the
best comic acting you'll ever see I mean
yeah insane Jeffrey Tambour ripped hor
just like two heavy weights on a CL just
a clinic it's just so good I was scared
of I was scared I waited till like 10
days on the set to introduce myself to
Rip Torn really yeah I was a little
scared of him but he was nice yeah he is
intim I think he was like a marine or
something yeah he because I remember
there's a story about during Dennis
Hopper's drug fuel days on Easy Rider
Rip Torn was originally supposed to play
the part they gave to Jack Nicholson and
when they sat down Hopper was such a
vicious drunk and awful and he ended up
pulling a knife on Rip Torn and I think
he just like like was able to get it
away from him from his Marine days and
and ripped towards like this I'm
not working with him you know wow you
heard the old Alec Baldwin Comedians and
Cars he's telling RI torn stories and
he's like and then I crack him in the
jaw and then I kicked him in the balls
and he goes Jesus when was this he goes
last summer he's just getting a bar
fight said like
68 that guy was so funny uh Defending
Your Life he's amazing oh yeah amazing
Men In Black he's amazing oh yeah that's
true he's is he alive no yeah he was he
was the best he was great who who else
so that was I mean man you you've been
in like everything I feel you were
Flight of the Concords too Flight of the
Concords I was in I think I was in the
wrestler that's right have you ever
mentioned that before I've never that's
the first time I don't talk about it
much but uh yeah was in the wrestler an
amazing movie wander lust oh yeah how
was working with Mickey roor
um I you know it was it was fine I
didn't
uh there wasn't a lot of chitchat he
takes like he's kind of he's kind of
like an intense guy he's he character
yeah he's just not someone who you're
not you don't really feel like oh he's
not going hey tell so tell me you do
stand up right right like he's not like
that he was perfectly as nice as he had
to be but you know there's a scene I
talked about this where he in the deli
where he started throwing stuff at me
like I didn't it wasn't in the script
and like he nailed me once with like a
bag of box of foil and was pretty
intense but whoa but there was like
scenes where Darren would say like right
start this tap by insulting his mother
then do a different then the second
takes now say this about his mother just
to get set him off yeah it just it was
kind of surreal because I used to I mean
I loved Mickey Rock when I was growing
up and then I'm doing scenes with them
insane yeah show went to the Venice Film
Festival where it won the biggest prize
there and that was cool yeah how was
Marissa she's nice I didn't work with
her but she came into the cellar not too
long ago sat down at the table and she's
super friendly looks great yeah yeah got
a huge crush on her yeah cousin Vinnie
come on yeah sign I never saw that movie
does that hold up did you really see my
cousin oh it's like one of the best
comedies ever great comedy oh it's like
perfect huh it's one of the it's like
one of the '90s '90s is such a good
decade of movies just like comedies but
Al but also like everything man like
it's true Forest Gump Saving Private
rhyme Pulp Fiction uh Boogie Nights yes
Fargo
yeah I like confidential good awesome I
mean the I feel like the '90s just like
crazy and for comedy is too it's it's do
you watch a lot of comedies like I try I
mean I I'll watch I'll watch here and
there like a new one just curious what
they're making but yeah like if I watch
them it's like Classics you know I don't
watch like I don't watch a ton of they
don't make that many new ones any not
really and the new on the new TV shows I
feel like they have to all have like
this heartwarming twist which kind of
feels like almost talking down to you
the fact they have to make this kind of
like warm blanket type of show which
it's fine if they make those but it
feels like that's the tone of everything
now yes enough's enough and I like that
shows like I love Eastbound and Down I
love that shows like that would kind of
like would push the envelope and really
be outrageous so are you are you
watching the other two have you seen the
other two no yeah it's great I cancel
it's all I've just caught on to it Molly
Shannon dude she's incredible but they
got some jokes in there where you're
like whoa Molly Shannon she's the nicest
I met her a couple I met her um I sent
her a fan letter when I was a kid when
she was on SNL really and she wrote back
I have an autograph picture of her
unless an assistant did that I don't
know I did that but then yeah I met her
once at uh Amy Schumer had a had a party
and she was there and Rachel Feinstein
and I were like panicking CU we were
both late for a seller spot and and
Molly Shannon H us panicking and
sprinted across the street and found us
a cab and I was like what an amazing
human that's great to just be that like
she's like just heard it was like I got
to help these that's what I me when I
said she's the nicest yeah but what do
you know her well no I used to know her
just
from um running into her I guess but
yeah so I don't really know her but
she's always extremely hey but I haven't
seen her I sat behind her on a flight
after that and I just I didn't want to
bother her so who El have You' been on
flights with let's get into this oh yeah
I don't who who do you got I've never
been on a flight with a cool guy oh uh
Warren batty what no you haven't I swear
you buried Warren batty I forgot I was
in the back he was with Anette Benning
oo first class I was in way in the back
or probably or I think La La in New York
actually yeah that's crazy that he he
just I it's crazy I think he flies
commercial he's just so famous he looked
rough I'll say that he that guy pulled
some he pulled some ass in his day yeah
I'm talking like 1980s Warren batty must
have just been on a mission pull up that
list I mean Bonnie and Clyde he is a
hunk that's a great movie he's got to be
in his 80s now right yeah yeah
bullworth Borth was kind of a Miss yeah
I'd say so the white guy rapping does
not usually play I hate it all it was a
good concept though but it just if they
went a different way with it it could
have been great El mcferson Goldie Han
cisb Connie Chung Barb baitman wow wow
Jason bitman he everybody this is
crazy Joanie Mitchell Mary Tyler
Moore good Bridget barau who the
elizab
Bergen was is like Murphy Brown she look
good late into however old she is she's
still
attractive man oh man oh man oh is that
Diane
Keat that's exciting and he also just
made cool he just has a cool career
yeah you know yeah Bonnie and cl what
was another good one I mean did he do
shampoo yeah oh boy he did uh shoot I
mean dick Trac I guess oh yeah I like
Bugsy did Bugsy met Ben that's awesome
movie Jewish gangsters baby y there you
go and he's the one who read the wrong
uh oh yeah winner
I view is supposed to be good oh mccab
and Mrs Miller uh Heaven Can wait's a
big
one ishar that was a
flop yeah not in a ton of uh
Blockbusters how about that that's why
it's F commercial
although he produced a ton of I
mean he made his money oh okay kid stays
in the
picture oh man wow role model with you
watch you watch movies though you you're
a big documentary guy right I like
documentaries I haven't I started
watching this one Janine Garo turned me
on to the series about the what is it
this tour to France Lance Armstrong It's
just about in general how they train
them and it's just it's pretty intense
man oh yeah like a sports guy but it's
like holy this is crazy but it's so
dangerous the way they're just doing I
mean I started watching some Formula 1
and just like you just admire the angles
they have to hit crazy yeah and then
just like one little false move and
there a pile up like yes eight you know
30 people behind you were crashing into
each other I know and they all flew
there they worked their whole life they
train and then one fall Ru it doesn't
look like fun no no it's a bike yeah
hell it's a bike on a dirt road it's
like swimming you can't really do and
it's not a thing you can like like
running you can kind of throw your
headphones in but biking you you need to
hear around that quickly he can be
listening to a podcast do the tour to
you flipped to your death cuz you were
listening to a Rogan app you guys
watching the new Beckham I hear it's
great that's pretty good he's got like a
docky series about him I didn't know he
was that good of a player I thought he
was just a hot guy no he was great it's
crazy to get a great player I don't
think he's like top 10 but he was a
great player great player who looks like
that and then starts dating uh on Mary's
a giant pop star I mean it's like a Chum
for for tabloids there was a funny thing
of them where I don't know if she was
doing like an IG live or something she
was doing something where she's like you
know we grew up uh we didn't have a lot
of money and he turns he kind of turns
in he goes uh he goes what what car did
your dad drive yeah is that in there
that's in there yeah yeah and she goes
oh and he goes what car and she goes a
Rolls-Royce was just like a funny uh
think she was just lying about not
having money I think she was yeah I
don't know know I mean but he's like
with her about it it's pretty
funny and he's uh I mean it seems like
they have a good thing though oh yeah oh
yeah got to hope so he saw her on TV and
goes I'm gonna marry that woman and his
friend's like ah shut up and then there
you go well that's what Harry did right
with Megan Markle oh yeah is that right
yeah he was like he know he called his
people and was like I want to dump a
load in that did wow he did it imagine
be able to do not those words maybe but
you know uh he's you're right for
there's some tension with this there's
some there's some Israel Palestine thing
going with dog and cat oh yeah they do
not like each other who's
who well if she's close to me I'm
guessing she's Israel yeah good point I
don't know she's just she's just trying
to
chill um what Todd do you have any
peeves oh yeah I was thinking about that
oh baby I F A General peeve M when when
things aren't user friendly like I I was
just did Seven Cities in nine days and
one of the airports I got out of like
didn't even have a sign for baggage
claim m like I had to walk like a good 5
minutes before like how do you not have
that everywhere or just like the signs
telling you I get to Uber and lift I was
just think which was the worst I don't
remember but then you call then you ask
them go all right you go through that
escalator go down four flights then go
up a flight then go across the parking
CR it's like maybe some signs what is
this Lawrence of Arabia it's like uber
everyone knows it's a real thing and we
want all use it and yeah we have to get
out of here so stuff like that made it
the worst you have to take you have to
take a bus to the thing I'm like taking
smaller and smaller Vehicles till I get
to the yeah exactly yeah so last
thing you want to do is get on
another shuttle after that's a good
peeve that's a good one but yeah the
signage that's a that's a great point
cuz then you got to ask a guy and they
hate you cuz they've been asked 10 times
like just put a big Uber sign there
should be more even when you're watching
you ever watching TV and there's like
give me a font the people on TV T what
do you mean if there's like sports
casters on and they don't font them I'm
like who is that guy I know the hell
this guy is you know I see yeah I
tweeted once about in a documentary
where they I said that they should had
that Chiron on if they refer to someone
like they show you at the beginning of
the documentary Bob he's the forensic
scientist and then he's in like three
hours later you forgot who he was like
show me again that's a good point always
tell me who that guy yeah this
is a this might be my stupidity talking
but sometimes I'm a sub tile guy I'm all
subtitle and they go too quick and now
I'm like losing I have to rewind cuz I
couldn't read it fast enough just type
out type out then go away do you guys
have that or you quick readers I can do
it all right I mean I you can pause I gu
everything now same not like I just CU
I'll end up rewinding and it's like
especially if you're watching a British
or yeah you'd be blown away how much you
miss but the user friendly thing is just
like uh you know like a lot of people
talk about like when you go to a
restaurant website and it's like I just
want to know how they when do you close
I just want to know when you close and
I'm clicking through link after link to
scrolling that should be yeah our motto
our promise they're like don't tell me
what you do with the potatoes just give
me a time well another one is uh
restaurants like here's here's an idea
ere order from the restaurant and not
through seamless or or one of these apps
and you save like $20 is that right oh
my God if look at like what the all
these added fees are the worst it's like
delivery fee service charge I think they
appreciate it if you don't order through
that app also cuz they they take a big
cut so why do people use it cuz it's so
easy ah it's seamless it seems there you
go I didn't know that I'm just going to
do that yeah it's better not problem is
not all of restaurants have websites
though that's what you're dealing with
right right damn the high-end ones I go
to all have a website
I got a uh you got a peeve yeah hit me
bike riders on the sidewalk are making
me crazy that happen a lot here and
there I mean they're in that lane the
lane even annoys me cuz it's like now
used to used to be able to just you know
Zing across when there weren't cars but
now you got to look for another thing
and they're not some of them are going
fast some of them are like you know and
they going on you know green lights for
us so that's what's crazy me but when
when they're on the the sidewalk like
you dude you're not the you're the
prey not the Predator you're supposed to
be with the cars not with us you know
right so that that annoys me no I'm with
you on that one I've had to pop up on
the sidewalk before on a bike but I
always make it quick yeah there's a
different I mean there people like
moving yeah that's silly come on so pack
sidewalk New York City what are we doing
here peeves peeves any any Rex
Todd this is a funny one a weird one but
there's this candy they sell at Trader
Joe's oh really C dragons pull it up
pull it up sin Dragon Trader Joe has
insanely good snacks it's such I love
their peanut butter yeah they oh look at
that bag of C
Dragons It's just cinnamon chewy candy
but it's good
one how'd you even find out about these
I just was shopping you know I do my own
shopping and I uh and I just kind of
noticed them and I gave him a world but
it's hard not to eat like a bag of sure
you rolled the dice on I usually someone
has to tell me something's good if I
before I roll the dice on yeah on a new
things roll the dice on cin dragons if
you like
cinnamon I encourage you to roll the
dice I want to try one I wish I know
Todd peeves are going next part are
going to be people who say roll the
dice yeah what uh yeah anything else
what else what's in your Trader Joe's
order um I always think that I'm going
to I just I hate eating in
home so I really yeah I hate it and uh
just a bummer I don't I just the cook
like especially you know pandemic I did
way more the part of the pandemic I did
way more cooking than I ever thought I
would ever do what's your what's your
go-to thing if you are cooking I mean I
remember making like a baked potato in
the microwave or some pasta but I never
really I never would do like I'm going
to do chicken aside of steamed
broccoli just like just have a
snc full of dishes like I've made like a
a baked potato like how are there nine
dishes in the yeah I just I'm
that's the
ADHD day day whatever also CU I think
it's just like it's it's very
overwhelming mhm But to answer your
question uh but like you know what Joe's
has but it's not there now maybe it's
seasonal they have this jalapeno
limeade oh that's good that sounds
really good that sounds great look it up
pull it up have you tried the cotton
candy grapes no what's that those are
next just what they sound like oh that
looks damn good that's right up my alley
pull it is pull up uh cotton candy
grapes too they're they're pretty good
cotton candy grapes are they just a type
of grape yeah but they're just they're
just the best gra you freeze fre freeze
them dude
yourself look at that I don't like the
Frozen oh you know what's good is that
Trader does the freeze-dried berry
medley oo those are good yeah
or those mangoes those dried the dried
mangoes with the chili on them this is
officially turned into the worst
date what uh Mark do you cook man no I
can't my parents ask me I'm like you I
like to eat out every meal and my
parents ask me uh you cooking yet and I
always say no and they're so
disappointed oh they're from New Orleans
right yeah Mom his mom's a real cook big
foodie lady so I should looks good I
mean I remember Brian ran had that bit
like everyone when they have the stuff
laid out in little bowls yeah I don't
remember the whole bit all they open the
oven and there's a there's a done one in
there already like oh that's the dream
but my lady Cooks she's she's good I
just got an oven like I had my building
the gas was up so I had like 10
months without an oven in this apartment
and I just got it so I started cooking a
little but did I have the same gas
problem did you get a knock off the rent
I I I don't rent this place you
know oh right true damn did you I I
emailed the guy cuz the the lady's like
I want to cook but I can't cook so I
said it and I got grapes are you
serious can I give one to her I wonder
no dogs can't have grapes or onions they
hate grape
culture statutory grape oh my God it's
good not a big grape guy but
what that's stupid I love that this good
tell you I went to bargo's uh Radio City
show incredible he did three I heard
yeah lot of grapes oh he's a grape guy
oh yeah he's he's looking thin when did
he when did he do Radio City right Sund
oh this past weekend who was with Zim
zimman veon was on the one I saw
okay shav he killed he killed yeah hea
he uh he opened they're old friends guy
a long time Nate's dad did a set he's a
Ian yeah magician and they love him I
hear they love him so yeah there he is
that's crazy I had no idea look at that
5,000 there's Old Vic we made fun of his
outfit for about an hour and a half he
is in a night the rockberry 2 yeah
there's chafing look at that wow there's
all of us just yucking it
up good crew good
times then he had lunch with Seinfield
the next day nice little trip mhm we got
to get him back on here man and he did
Fallon with thean Laura that's kind of
fun with who Ian laara oh double comic
those are the best ones the best the
best one the best set I ever had in a
late night show was the guest it was on
Conan and it was Bill haer Bill Burr and
then me and I was like man what a fun
one to be on oh wow yeah did I get a
little intimidated by that I was a
little intimidated but I had a couple
whiskies and I think that put me you
drank whiskey before you I had two
whiskies before I went out
really that's ballsy could wouldn't be
able to talk um I don't know I just felt
loose and I was like let's go
but I was yeah I was definitely that was
on what show on Conan bur Burr had a
great Caitlyn Jenner bit that he did
before I went out and I was like I was
watching him laughing but also kind of
like well my shit's not going to be as
jarring to them now kind of it's almost
like gray I I had another one where I
followed an actress who was not getting
much from the crowd
and yeah it was not as it was not as
good a set yeah yeah I love following a
comic who doesn't like the crowd yes
that always anytime someone says oh
they're not that good it's like oh
they're going to be good they don't like
you right they're not buying what you're
selling you get to be the hero the best
is when you go though and eat it even
worse and you're like right and
that that could happen also well these
are damn good those are good I
love those things man M yeah are
you you're a big cotton candy grape guy
billbert had a run on Conan where he was
doing panel that was like legendary yeah
for like a couple years do you you
prefer you say you prefer standup or
panel when you do it I think I like the
prestige or the false Prestige of doing
panel but uh I mean it there were times
when I've done it and you do end up
doing your bits and it seems a little
canned in a way totally and you never
know what he'll say right right and if
he's yeah I mean generally they've been
no one's really stepped on my stuff but
yeah but yeah it's all over for me man I
had a good run you're doing great man
you get the new special out yeah yeah
all
right call more late night what happened
here we're having a good we're having a
good time here start crying unlike we're
going to edit this to make it better not
worse there you go look at that 290,000
views is that good hey not bad they
going to hit a million in a year I'd say
a year is that that seems like
forever million people's a million
people helps I think it helps in the
road does it help get a paid special it
might probably or a better or
a you have to a mill you think I think
that's the cut off do you still try do
you still do a lot of or do you want to
do a lot of acting cuz I know you do uh
I kind of miss it I'd like to do
something I I kind of wouldn't mind a
regular job acting job I don't know
really like a sitcom just so I could get
sag Insurance oh I got it pretty good
insurance Health yeah yeah no Dental how
did you get it uh did a couple of gigs
gigs like TV gigs really yeah yeah they
all added up enough to get the insurance
wow what TV gigs did you do well you
know I don't know hey I did the Schumer
show a few times
uh scale okay what else bunch of app
midnights scale yeah yeah it's all scale
but midnight that was like years ago
wasn't it yeah yeah I got in early at
midnight was kind of fun to do back in
the day back homework though yeah but I
kind of like I prefer that to just going
out there and winging it I like having
bits ready it's kind of
fun man uh they're bringing it back yeah
who's is it no host or I guess there's
no host right that's the whole thing I
want to pay someone cuz I think was not
making money well ain't going to be Roy
wood I'll tell you that I could think he
could still be the host though Daily
Show I mean I think I he took himself
out of the running I didn't think he
took himself out of the running I
thought he took himself off the show no
I think he's out I think he's out I
think that was a statement like I'm not
doing it oh yeah I think you know I
think he made himself available for long
enough and and they made it pretty clear
they're not going with him I think they
want like in what their mind it's all
about data now to them they don't care
no-brainer with him well to comedians
it's a no-brainer or to you know to a
network whose you know Prestige factor
is now reruns to the office right
exactly maybe they you know and not
nothing against Roy wood we're all a
huge fan but I think they wanted
something a little younger sexier kind
of hipper is he he's young he's what is
he 45 younger he's younger than that oh
really still he's young he's got two
kids I assume all right close I won by
point was very close on that one but you
were technically right but yeah it's
also just like isn't that the point of
Comedy to cut your teeth and earn it I
mean fine if we if we're trying to find
the next James Bond I understand if
you're trying to franchise a young guy
or whatever but if we're trying to get
the Best comedian agreed the prime is
really growing it's like as you get
older I would think I
mean totally I just think every comic we
talk about is like the great they got
better go back to the headline leaving
The Daily Show but would but
would I think Roy would be a decent
James
Bond see he's he's considering the host
if offer yeah he he would do it I'm sure
but oh I didn't know that I didn't know
that either I thought he took himself
out but you should listen to me man
up dude no one's more tapped in
to the show biz than I am oh look at
that how is SNL able to do the show with
the strike going on that strike's over
the writer strike's over shag is still
gone as of now by the time this is out
it might be over but uh I don't know
it's a good question I maybe I should
have brought that up on the that's a
great question are they not the are the
performers is there some way around they
got to be sag nwor oh yeah I don't get
it maybe they just assume it'll be over
by then
scabs uh yeah I didn't know that
good question Pete Davidson's hosting I
know how do you like that well uh Todd
plug some besides special what else do
you have going on where you going be
special I got I'm on this joke this half
joking tour which is half first half is
jokes second half is crowd work it's the
best thing you can do when you don't
have a new
hour and that's going all over and uh go
to my website todd.com probably get some
clips out of that too you got to film
those oh I know I saw a guy with a funny
that guy Alex Hooper I think his name is
he had a funny tweet where he's like a
comic doing 10minute set you're next
wait let me just set shout out my
seventh audience
[Laughter]
camera it's that's it's tough to do on
showcases if you're headline to show
it's fine it's I mean I could have done
it this past run and we did a crow work
special was a great a great idea you did
it before everyone was doing it yeah
true I'm the the
Renegade uh oh Bell house that's an
afternoon show the bellous in New York
nice yeah 4:30 all right the dog
snoring Nola bruingo hey is that good
yeah up
bad paper tiger go see Texas Cleveland
Atlanta New Orleans Pittsburgh
Todd
raspberry yeah is there anything yeah my
Instagram is Todd Barry uh but check out
the special on YouTube one of the best
TR like truly a killer comedian and and
it's a killer special so watch it now
guys after this go check it out tell a
friend thanks for me of course man we'll
bump you up to
300K views Providence Cleveland coming
to Grand Rapids Denver Grand Junction
Hartford Concord New Hampshire Mobile
Alabama Nola Santa Rosa Sacramento Omaha
Kansas City Norfolk Baltimore Birmingham
oh I'm doing the beacon I'm announcing
that yeah January 24th yeah hopefully we
can add one who knows doing the beacon
easy so yeah markom comedy.com get some
Bodega cat tell a friend queef it up get
a mug get a cup this weekend you could
see me Pittsburgh uh what do we have no
no no you it's come
before yeah yeah yeah yeah Pittsburgh
Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati Indie uh
all this week and then uh November 4th
the big one MSG uh theater at MSG New
York New York baby November 4th then I'm
all over
Australia uh hell yeah and then we got
you know Vegas Tampa Fort Meyers Buffalo
Springfield Missouri Madison Philly
Dania Beach Omaha Dallas OKC Irvine
going back to the clubs yeah I'm I'm
going to make sure it's airtight for
when I film in uh in Boston at the
Wilbur March 7th and 8th so filming a
new special March 7th and 8th and uh
check it out March 7th and 8th Wilbur
Boston hell yeah and definitely watch
Todd special right now and uh and and
order some Bodega cat at Bodega cat
whiskey.com we love you guys and Trader
Joe send us some free we pluged the
hell out of you these grapes are
[Music]
Good's talking
sh
roof coming and naked Samu is feeling
dangerous I'm lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I remember
her and I get down in the same
way we
might
be
true